[Music]
this is the battle of the two heaviest
hitting tablets on the market today in
2012. the new ipad 3 and the asus
transformer prime and the ipad is the
boss of all ios devices and the
transformer prime is the king of all
android tablets and from a purely
hardware perspective they are pretty
similar slabs of glass from the outside
now to be fair uh just to get out the
way the transformer prime is the thinner
of the two tablets and it is the lighter
of the two by just a few ounces not the
substantial difference but now you know
and both have their own unique very high
quality metal backs that's actually
a trademark and probably why they are so
expensive and comparing button layouts
you'll see that the power button and
volume rockers are in the same spot on
both tablets pretty much linked together
and on the front the transformer prime
is a 10.1 inch sheet of glass while the
ipad is a slightly smaller 9.7 inch
sheet of glass and a home button
you also have cameras on the back of
these bad boys a 5 megapixel on the back
of the ipad and an 8 megapixel camera on
the back of the transformer but honestly
it's a tablet i mean they both take
decent photos and they both take it at a
decent speed the interface is fine but
nothing to write home about i mean i'm
sure we're all familiar with the fact
that taking pictures on a tablet is
forbidden among geeks i mean come on you
look ridiculous i mean you just might as
well use your face i mean you look just
as dumb
like really but honestly the
front-facing cameras on these two
devices are far more useful for stuff
like google plus hangouts and facetime
calls but as we all know this isn't just
the ipad 3 versus the transformer prime
this is also apple's new dual core a5x
chip with quad-core graphics versus
nvidia's quad-core tegra 3 chip with
tons of corso graphics so we know that
we have some performance tests here i
started out with less intensive app
equivalence on both devices and worked
my way up in intensity as you can see
but what i basically found was that in
real world use these two perform very
very close to each other sometimes the
ipad would pull ahead and you know
render a web page quicker
and maybe be a little bit more
responsive on a website and other times
the transformer prime would open a few
apps faster and be just better in some
other categories but as you can see here
it was never like a substantial
difference where i would just sit back
and say wow this tegra 3 just destroyed
the ipad with quad core or i would never
say wow this if this a5x just blows the
tiger 3 out of the water i never ever
found myself saying that don't believe
what you see in these silly
cross-platform benchmarks they're almost
never completely accurate so pay
attention to what you see in real life
and both obviously offer a ton of top of
the line snappy performance so it's all
good it's all good these just work very
very well
you've probably already seen my
transformer prime review where i was
playing this game here it's called
riptide gp and this is great way to show
off the graphics on this 10.1 screen
1280 by 800 lots of pixels and it drives
it very very well good stuff tiger three
the new ipad has a few internal upgrades
to help keep up with four times as many
pixels at 2048 by 1536 display so it
gets a little bit warm it has a larger
battery but overall graphics still look
great and the game i'm playing here on
the ipad is called real racing 2 hd and
i gotta say i am a boss at this game
even in the crappiest of cars just
saying
oh yeah
look at that just look at that
so aggressive
but none of this means anything if you
can't connect to the internet on both of
these have had minor wi-fi issues they
both have a metal back so that was kind
of the deal when people are trying to
figure out hey does this not have as
good an internet connection but overall
i got decent results so it's nothing
really to worry about on either of these
tablets also the battery life between
these two tablets was about the same
easily six or seven hours of regular use
though the ipad has a larger battery
which means it's going to take longer to
charge it fully that's just simple
physics so which one do you get uh well
i gotta say it mostly depends on whether
you like the dead easy simplicity of ios
5.1 or the quirky but kind of fun and
customizable sophistication of android
4.0 there are a couple of reasons why i
love android so much i use a lot of
google services like google talk google
voice google calendar and uh youtube so
it helps that i have android but the
funny thing is widgets dude you have no
idea how awesome widgets on android are
until you don't have them anymore i
swear widgets are very very useful
pretty underrated right now but i gotta
say the most compelling reason to get
the ipad 3 is easily easily the retina
display i'd say it's even a reason to
sell your ipad one or two most of you
don't know this i had an ipad 2 for
about two weeks a little while ago just
testing it out but it didn't really
impress me and i returned it
but i would actually rather have an ipad
3 than an ipad 2. having used them both
with this new 2048 by 1536 display i
actually think that it is worth that
upgrade now keep in mind the new
transformer prime infinity is going to
be coming out hopefully in april and is
going to have a
1920x1200 hd display which is also
kick-ass so stay tuned for my review of
that tablet but until then this is
absolutely the king of mobile displays
and thumbs up to apple just very well
done on this ips display but in my
opinion you can't go wrong with either
of these they're the kings of their
kingdoms and they deserve their titles
so it's your cash put your money where
your heart is
so there you have it guys the choice is
yours ipad 3 or asus transformer prime
and hey leave a thumbs up on this video
if you enjoyed it the ratings really do
help out a lot and i will talk to you
guys in the next video thanks for
watching
peace
[Music]
you